welcome to this video playing Michael
Cawley owner with the Spanish flag so
isn't this some what we had if you play
back and call you shouldn't have an
Italian flag or maybe the US flag not
Spanish okay does not have a name and I
am ok but it's got a bit pretty big
writing him Jackie let's see what he
what he can do against against misamis
playing a slightly unusual move order
should I play Queenie to hear maybe I
can can play without them every year and
just play with f4 okay
hmm text takes you five
I can take is also and go here
complicated stuff is just in time to get
down if f5 is a move that would be
excellent to get in but difficult to do
an audi for hang so probably have to
cover that probably an hour 97 ER is
just in time to get this blocked
and now I can play a five yes I know he
can play on 93 but it still is dangerous
yeah I will play it I will play it's no
use in and doing anything passive him
okay this I didn't see your horse
yeah this is just an exchange and this
really terribly strong night anyway to
fight here I don't know very little very
little opportunities takes Queen takes
maybe I getting Bishop f2 and take you
forward yeah black at some of course
clearly clearly better here here this is
strong i am with the check check check
check yeah okay white resigns hmm maybe
i shouldn't take the problem here is
really bishop a6 as well this is this is
too much really now black is better
y'all ready maybe I shouldn't I
shouldn't take on your form I was
thinking about the idea with taking was
to maybe get in m5 this sum was my
rationale I should probably ignore it
something like this yeah black black
takes I have the check typical sack him
this is a normal position I should
shouldn't take here or at least delay it
to a point where it makes makes more
sense the other ideas of course 22 just
not player for play play something start
with Bishop g5 many now this could be an
idea I don't really believe very much in
blacks
him losing a temper with Bishop a 6 and
so on I made moves that I want to want
to make any way but maybe em yeah I must
have white Bishop e-form he really gets
in this counter play too quickly I
should take actually I should take this
is this is better in comparison this is
going here something like that here and
then I've got 90 cigna it's also not
good now now then Bishop before it's
really questionable and after that you
just did a very clean mop-up job I'm
really in bad shape here yeah Bishop a6
was very clean something like this isn't
isn't even in an even so clear and our
computer gives wide a clear advantage
okay this I didn't really expect but
it's at least not Keely irfu this is for
example winning with Queen age 60 k a
very nice job by him okay thanks for
watching